if you look at the p&l statement for
uufc payroll accounted for like 44% of
the expenses the rest of it with
marketing and all the reinvestment they
do to grow the business you know so it's
like on Bellator the payroll might be
70% of the revenue but zero marketing
zero pfl there's only one thing that
they need to do in order to continue to
gain this profile and that's spend more
money on marketing and they're doing a
good job they got Francis enanu they got
Jake Paul and there's these other guys
who can be a mouthpiece and be a big
platform type of person to be able to
help grow the entire the entire brand
the UFC they just put on this show and
they sell pay-per-view and they do it
because they because everyone knows
about it